so we selected mihai because he um is
one of the co innovators of a very
recent breakthrough in um in databas
orian systems namely a completely new
way of looking at incremental view
maintenance uh which is a fundamental
problem in datab basis and what Mii and
his cers including valan and did was to
take a new look using dig Digital Signal
processing so Mii please take it
away this
can I TR
again how about now is it
better me now it's on because the
is well oh this is good okay so this is
uh called dbsp and uh it's a theoretical
talk I I came here I thought you know
Simons is a theoretical Institute so I
have to put some math but I I'm actually
not a mathematician myself but
fortunately the math is very very simple
as you will see if you want to know the
details there's a paper behind this it
was published in the last vldb all right
so this is all about motivated by
incremental computation so we'll start
being informal but we'll become
mercilessly formal later so let's say
you have a program and I I apologize I I
I was under the assumption that you
haven't seen Val tanan talk two days ago
or that if you have seen it you've liked
it so much that you'd like to hear again
some of the aspects in there so uh let's
say you have a program that computes
something based on some input and gives
you an output and then let's say you
have a notion of a change of your input
so you add something to your input
something small and then let's also
assume that often if you change the
input slightly the output also changes
slightly so incremental computation
means you want to reuse whatever you
computed previously and not do the
effort and the just compute maybe ideal
this change so in general there's a lot
of very nice work about this uh many PhD
Theses it's very hard to Define
precisely but there is one area where
this works really well and that's
databases and why because in databases
these programs P are what people call
queries and database have a natural
notion of a change it's whatever you add
or delete in a table uh usually a
transaction is what we call a change a
set of changes in a set of tables and
also in databases often databases are
humongous but they are continuously
incrementally Changed by adding and
deleting grows in uh and this these
changes tend to be much smaller than
database themselves
okay so what what is this about dbsp is
a is a very simple streaming language it
only has four operators and I'm not
going to show all of them to you and
it's a pun come from Digital Signal
processing I actually happen to have an
Masters in in Signal processing which I
never use for anything so it was a shock
to me that it actually is uh applicable
in this domain and then what using this
language that what is nice about the bsp
is that using the bsp we can Define what
it means precisely for something to be
incremental and they'll argue that
incremental computation only makes sense
in a streaming context and then what is
also very nice is that given an
arbitrary dbsp program we can generate
automatically an incremental program out
of it so and also you know dbsp this
would be a cute thing but also we have a
recipe for implementing essentially
anything you can write in a database
language like SQL or even data log we
can Implement any these programs in the
bsp and as a corollary of all these
facts is essentially we can
incrementalization um so we only need
two ingredients a billion groups so
bilan group I remind you is just a set
with a plus a minus and a zero which has
some nice properties we we'll need it to
be you know associative commutative and
so and functions and this is the the
entire base of this Theory this is a
very simple algebra that is needed and
it's so simple in fact that one of our
qus managed to fully verify all the
theorems in the paper that we have so we
at least know that the theory is sound
and we have a hope that the
implementation will also be
correct we have an implementation too
I'll only say a few words about it at
the end now the basic ingredient we're
going to talk about is a stream and
think of a stream as an infinite Vector
index by time mathematically speaking
it's just a function from time which I'm
assuming it starts at sometime zero and
giving you a value of some type A now
we'll put a very strong constraint
apparently on the streams is we require
all the values in the Stream to be from
some commutative group ah okay yeah this
is again useless I'll show you that
actually this constraint is not too bad
in practice it can be uh in fact it
makes things much much easier and is
applicable in real
databases then everything is a
computation on streams streams operators
are just functions that take streams and
produce other streams this is a unary
stream operator you can have binary
stream operators dbsp uses only very few
kinds we can write lit lot lots of
functions on streams but we use only
very few of them so all our functions
are causal in the sense that they
produce an output only based on the
previous inputs they've seen and they
are time invariant they never they are
not allowed to keep a clock so they they
have to anyway that doesn't matter too
much so this is all by the way these are
all Concepts that are very well known in
the DSP literature if you happen to be
familiar with that so how we can we
create stream operators well the
simplest way you can create a stream
operator is by taking a scalar function
and just applying it to every element of
a stream that is called lifting and in
fact mathematically is just function
composition because remember streams are
functions from time to values and you
just apply the the function you compose
it with the stream function
itself now as a cute fact the streams
themselves with the lifted operations of
plus minus and zero they form also a
commutative group so there will be
commutative groups
everywhere okay okay now this is one way
you can create stream functions and
second way is you can take primitive
stream functions and compose them let's
say uh circuits and data flow um
programs if you want okay now there is
one interesting stream operator which is
used a lot in digital signal processing
which is called the delay and this name
Z comes from something called the Z
transform which is actually a polinomial
with coefficients Associated the same
values but I don't want to go into that
so the description is really simple if
you have a stream of values the delay
operator will output a zero and then
your original
stream look simple right well just with
these three ingredients we can start
building some very very interesting
computations so anybody want to venture
what this does well you're not allowed
to say
anything so let's look at it a little
bit so we have a stream we delay it we
negate it and add it to itself
right so you can write a simple equation
that the current output is the previous
the current the current input minus the
previous input and this is nothing but a
discrete derivative so if you think of
your stream as a continuous function of
time this is the the discrete part of
that so what does this mean well well
this is a very useful operator so we'll
call it D and then if o is the stream if
you have an input stream of for example
of numbers then all the output is the
stream of changes to those numbers so
each value is the difference between it
the current input and the previous one
okay so this this operator alls us to
compute Deltas from from values all
right now even a simpler circuit which
looks a little bizarre right so we take
a stream and then we take its own output
delayed and add it to itself it seems to
be like a recursive definition and it is
a recursive definition but actually we
can show easily that it's well form one
maybe I shouldn't have shown us shown
this yet so the first output will be the
first input because you get a zero and
then the teth output will be the current
input plus the previous output right
this is what this line says and this is
actually a system of equations which
happens to be is like an you can do a
Goan elimination and get this unique
solution every output is the sum of
everything you've seen so
far and this actually is really nothing
but the the discrete form of the
indefinite integral of the the stream
values if you consider them as a
function of time this is a very useful
operator and it does the inverse of what
the the the derivative did if you give
it a stream of changes this is the
previous stream of changes it will give
you back the original stream and this
operators are defined for any stream
they are total functions and no not not
only that but they are inverses of each
other when you compose them they give
you
nothing so what does this have to do
with databases well let me make the
first claim here that that all databases
that you know of are streaming databases
so you know my SQL is a streaming
database why okay so let's take a
database what is it it it is a set of
tables and that what is a transaction to
database it's it's a change to the
database now the beautiful thing that
people in database have done is they
they said transactions are linearizable
so it means that there is a definite
order in which the transactions could
have committed so let's take this order
and let's call this a stream this is the
the transactions that you have applied
to your database in the order they have
been applied to your database all right
now to each of these transactions
corresponds a snapshot of the database
so this is your initial database this is
the database after you have applied one
transaction two and so so on what is the
relationship between these two streams
well it's a very nice relationship that
the database is the actual integral of
the stream of transactions right how do
you get to the third snapshot you just
apply the transaction 0 1 two 3 right so
it's a very very simple relationship so
that's why I say that databases have our
streaming systems by the way yeah
question you assumed your operators were
a but datab excellent question EXC so I
I'll answer that question in a second
yeah so uh I am I I asked the database
to be an a billiant group but database
are not a billiant groups but still this
works even if you have a weaker notion
of a plus okay another thing database
views so uh a database view is
essentially a virtual function that you
apply to your database this is an
example create some view as function
from some table in database what does it
mean to create a view remember we have a
database is a sequence of snapshots so
it means that for every snapshot of the
database you have a snapshot the
corresponding snapshot of The Bu so what
this means is actually this views this
the view stream the views form a stream
the database form a stream and the
relationship between the two is the
lifted query the query is just a
function and this this is this is the
definition of what it means to lift a
query so views are lifted queries so not
only databases are streaming systems but
views are streaming systems computed by
databases okay so this is an equation on
streams DB is a stream of database
Snapchats V is a stream of view
snapshots okay so now I will Define what
it means to incrementally maintain this
view so first of all what we'll do is
we'll compose the two definition I gave
you remember I said that the database
itself as a stream is the integral of a
a set of of a stream of transactions so
I just put this two diagrams together
and now I'll make it symmetric I'll I'll
differentiate the stream of views what
will we get we will actually get a
stream of changes to the view so this
this computation is always defined no
matter what the streams are and given a
stream of changes to your trans database
will give you a stream of changes to the
view the view can be arbitrarily defined
I will call this the incremental view
maintenance of the view so this is
slightly different from what database
people call incremental view maintenance
they actually call this stream the
increment of view maintenance but I
think this definition is much better for
two reasons at least one is that because
these are changes we can hope that they
are small your view is large you know
you have to query The View so you'll do
as much work to retrieve the data as
you've done say you won't save anything
really then second it is compositional
because both inputs and outputs are
changing
then uh you can compose these kind of
pipelines and this is the fundamental
sandwich of incremental view mat it's a
definition we can argue whether the
definition is is right or wrong but I
think it's a very useful definition so
it's your query sandwich between a
differentiator and integrator so so keep
this in mind now if we just want to
implement this it's very expensive
because you have to build the database
run the query and then comput the Deltas
but often we can optimize this formula
significantly so and but I want to point
out something very interesting most
people who do incremental view
maintenance they try to compute the
derivative of the query itself with
respect to its input well we don't need
to do that we only differentiate streams
and integrate streams and this is always
defined Lo is that we have no idea what
this query does this definition is works
for any query so it's a very powerful
definition okay now there's some two
properties that makes this very useful
the first one is that if you have a
chain of queries and you want to compute
the incremental version you can just
incrementalization
this is structur recursion you can
recursively decompose the subqueries and
incrementalization component
queries another thing is if your
operator is linear remember these are
operators over groups so there's a
notion of linearity then the query and
its incremental version are identical
and this this is the the top definition
is this box the bottom definition is
this box so there's a huge speed up
between those two implementations and
this is important because most operators
in SQL for example almost all relational
operators are almost
linear and this works for recursive
functions too so you can do recursive
queries there's you can express uh fix
point on streams using circuits like
this and it works now database are not
ailan groups as you pointed out but
there's a simple trick which has been
known for a long time uh using Z
relations or Z sets essentially you just
put an integer with weight on each row
and what a table just becomes a map with
a finite support where which Maps each
row to an integer weight and using this
you can essentially represent tables
multisets and changes to tables and this
is actually an ailan group because it's
a function that maps to Z which is an
ailan group and you can do group y group
Y is actually this function which
because this is an ailan group this is
also an ailan group so you can do nested
relations as
well and we can Implement all SQL and
moreover we can implement it efficiently
so does it work well actually I uh
together with some colleagues we quate
our research jobs and founded this fera
startup to try to prove that this is
actually a viable technology and we have
open source implementations the bsp run
time in Rust which implements Primitives
for all the operators that you have in a
normal query language and we have a full
seal compiler that generates code for
this runtime so we actually think it
works you can pass 7 million uh uh SQL
logic test tests for example so we can
support the full SQL language for sure
so this is the picture I want to leave
you with with so databases views and
streams they are not foreign objects
actually in fact you cannot separate
them they are just different projectes
of the same interesting mathematical
object okay let's
thank so we have time for one
question
yes so the question is what is the
negative weight yeah negative weight
essentially represents a deletion so
using Z set we can represent not only
tables but also deletions from tables so
uh let me answer this question in a
different way uh I hope I have time to
tell a
joke how can I stop you okay so uh
there's this question you know so uh a
puzzle like two people enter a house and
then three come out so different people
have to explain what goes on you know
and the you know the doctor says
obviously you know they multiplied you
know they there was a baby and then you
know the sociologist says there was
somebody in the house and then the
mathematician says one more person will
go in and then the house will be
empty so that's exactly how this sets
work really it's perfectly
consistent okay folks I think this is
all the time we have and let's thank the
speak
up uh so
this is the end of the first half